yeah
[Music]
website website make it website website
me making it website my website make it
website website website website making
websites - making website make the
website I'd make making website make the
website Squarespace squarespace.com
promo code Hannibal for 10% off your
first purchase do it get a website check
it out
tomoco Hannibal yeah know that talk
space life is tough you don't have to do
this alone
go to talk space.com slash Hannibal
text-based therapy I'll tell you how it
works I did it
you go to talk space.com slash Hannibal
they'll sign you up you sign up they'll
match you with a therapist that can help
you with your needs
you talk to that their vision you tell
them what you're working on what your
problems are what your goals are what
your dreams are and they will help you
out there's it's great look at the
reviews online look at the articles on
medium.com
and other online publications talk
space.com promo
[Laughter]
takk space talk space.com hey we're at
the wheat Maps house so this is going
exactly how you thought the wheat Maps
house we maps late unorganized [ __ ]
moving around
everybody's moving around chaos a dog
with a shirt this is very on brand for
the wheat mAbs house we rolling over
here okay let's uh let's get in some
fake applause real quick it's to make it
feel like a sow and also just to give my
hey welcome so alive
handsome rebel podcast I'm your host
Hannibal Burres Tony trim right here
we're here in the weed Maps house during
Coachella weekend how you feelin man I'm
still I hate too many edibles and I woke
up a high which never happens but I that
happen yesterday it was too many you
know I smoked occasionally I'll have a
small amount I'm good a small amount but
it is all of the we was here yeah and I
ingested weed and three different I
smoked a gummy bear the gummies a bunch
of dog you were eating those things like
skittles like they didn't have weed in
them yeah actually tasted good yeah I
was appreciating them as candy and that
as drugs yeah and so we sit here today
you should welcome my guests yeah
welcome our guests please welcome from
8:45 last night ish coke Coachella act
Phantogram
[Applause]
welcome hey thanks for coming all right
what's this guy's name this is this is
Leroy Brown Leroy Brown Leroy the good
boy a KA aka el chapo yeah aka aka
badass [ __ ] badass [ __ ]
I feel like you just made that up
no right here I did I wouldn't okay how
just set go last night it was awesome
yeah it was fun yeah it was really fun
we played our little hearts out and had
a good set time and danced her a little
more time yeah we're on time no sound
issues you know one our managers are
really mean so they make sure that we
have no fun no chela and we just go on
stage and we play you did your thing
right Jim we we wanted to see your set
but we didn't because we we don't have
Coachella passes it's a tough it's a
tough ticket
it's like $8,000 $8,000 aren't they
playing Bonnaroo also are you are you
guys doing Bonnaroo no are you high
right now
yes yeah my acid my acid just kicked in
so walls are breathing right now and I
am NOT I listen to the new album it was
good
clock then thank you clocked in at 10
minutes
no 10 tracks 37 minutes and where's the
rest of it what do you think about what
do you think about that short record is
punk rock 37 minutes dad son get it done
I'll killer no filler I feel like
what about the fans that say hey once
more and I don't and they don't like
repeating songs then we give them some
more you don't give them some more yeah
see I'm not a fan then you go listen to
the Drake record that's 30 tracks Oh
[Music]
22 is it really 20 22 that's why it's
called more live because a lot of tracks
I mean I mean I've been messing around
with it there many yeah I've never used
one you never use a theremin no I
haven't it just feels good by the way we
got we got auto-tune here you can just
hit that and then Auto to it and then
you got drums
feel free to feel free to play with the
toys you got would you can you play this
together you want to do your hand in my
hands and make it like a thing would you
consider yourself a dog mom your dogs
over there
would you consider yourself a dog mom
well yeah it's kind of embarrassing to
say yes but yeah he's my son yeah how
old is he - two years old - yeah two
years old areas you have a sample him
and put him on a song we haven't done
that yeah we've got to do that I was
sometimes we sample his farts that's
great so you just gotta put him in a
studio and just wait for the magic to
happen burritos how long did it take to
finish this new album we kind of wrote
it and recorded it in six months six
months yeah six months yes 37 minutes
[Laughter]
Wow
not a good return on time investment do
you ask me it smooth though you all do
you uh you ever have sexier music
I bet Miguel does absolutely some people
that seem like they would like Miguel
see why he might have sex there's our
music here's my theory on and I said
it's theory with musician phrase because
he makes instrumentals so he says it's
okay to [ __ ] to your music if it's just
beats but if it's vocals is no good what
do you think yeah yeah I agree it's
about another person yeah that's
extremely uncomfortable I would think to
meet a smash hit off of your the new
album is in the catchiest song is the
hit my heart is everybody got a little
bit of Houyhnhnm okay yeah does that
speak to you yeah what what what what
makes what makes you stand for being a
little bit of whatever you got to be
first I'll ask you about the song before
I say what I felt about the song I
thought this anemic that's not what it
was about it was a metaphor
so when you say everybody got a little
bit of hoenn was it about [ __ ] it or was
it something about Syria some [ __ ] we
all got a little bit of ho in us is it
we leaves it up we leave it up for you
to interpret for your own self okay so
yeah so that's why I asked you okay well
people ask me or ask us about our music
when you do that it's open for our
I'm saying right think it a little bit
you know makes you think harder it makes
you maybe get a little bit higher
yeah that helps I got a little bit high
so now when I think about everybody got
a little bit a whole wedding I think
about skis beef brisket try to beef
brisket delicious Schlotzsky's welcome
everybody's Coachella seeking this
muhfucka oh you bought the shirt cheers
welcome oh oh I'm a terrible I'm sorry
for everybody in the front row to be
topless cuz I feel like if you're gonna
be you know we're the only ones seeing
it we're the only one see no no there's
no it's a good I'm just I'm just saying
if you want to do it with the next
artist that comes in or this we can
write it down on a piece of paper you
make the rules I'll make the road okay
listen forget that what would have you
played Coachella before we have yeah
yeah we were 12 years old so 2011
there's so six years later you're back
yeah we're back well money more famous
huge has the writer changed the
treatment better go karts golf carts
golf carts and we also have we asked for
a herd of puppies I heard and you make
your dog walk in front of them
yes deleted it's mostly for him your dog
look like his sleep is chilling with me
man he likes me
Media obligations chale chale is wearing
them out yeah jellyboy you're in between
third days you're on the road I'm giving
you a scenario sorry okay
stop sore bus okay random town Chinese
buffet you only have three minutes to
get in and out what do you grab frog
legs frog legs
yeah toilet paper toilet paper true it's
all the paper frog legs and toilet paper
this is the name of our next record Oh
y'all it separates or buses vibes yet no
we don't hate each other enough no no I
mean we ride together we have a crew
yeah we're gonna do buses two buses oh
we hate oh [ __ ] yeah I know
buzzes dude I know it's crazy yeah
gratulations
thank have you ever been on a tour bus
before yeah I have one on my tour but it
wasn't a great economical decision feels
great though how was the break-even tour
we had many parties and every city knows
boy it was great it was a good time
exactly you can open up yes
from the [ __ ] car door open ah you
eyes
I'll spread my legs and fly how much how
much money exactly do you all have I
stopped counting me to stop town so
[ __ ] rich yeah ain't that got down
those pot of fat sex
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'll leave I'll leave your songs on
repeat out of support so do you get paid
more for the amount of people that come
into this room like you count heads kind
of thing or is it more of how many
people listen to the podcast I don't
even know anymore I just I just do it as
a reason to play the theremin in front
of people and to give free theremins you
know trying to add them up we don't do
it we're gonna do a theremin battle okay
oh yeah I use both hands you have a you
know y'all familiar with Thundercat yes
Thundercats is really into his cat he's
uh he's made two songs about his cat and
they're both beautiful do you have any
songs about your dog no so you don't
like your dog we don't really like him
we just bring them around cuz we get
more more attention Instagram yeah oh
yeah Instagram loves dog yeah that's why
that's it
this dogs they have more followers than
us on Instagram and people and then
people comment and other dog accounts
comment yeah yeah looking good out there
[Laughter]
check out my exec out of my account
check out my adventure dogs make
appearances and [ __ ] did I ever make out
this dog at the Webby Awards what did I
ever beef Instagram animal beef that's
not this is to understand and kindness
in the Instagram talk so since you don't
have a song about your dog I think okay
you if you get this would blow up
Instagram what's the name of the dog
again Leroy Brown okay the good boy all
right well let's
I will show you think when you see it
this your feeling when you see look
relax relax
you know these people the cameras and
the equipment he is calm
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] is hot keep it going keep it going
this is hot my acid is so kicking in
right oh that was a great that was great
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah okay that was fun
any other questions other stupid
questions that was amazing you guys are
awesome for that all right buddy
thanks you guys
all right one more time for Phantogram
everybody Fanta ground
I think Leroy wants to stay Leroy yeah
he's like your that song didn't have a
hook need to finish this goddamn song I
like the concept I liked it
who are you excited to see excited to
see yeah Kendrick obviously Kendrick
yeah I want to see Kendrick also did you
anybody here see Travis Scott yesterday
oh yeah yesterday I want to have a Scott
was yesterday
yeah yep pick up the phone baby see I
can do pick up the phone
[Music]
you know a parameter letting me go
I don't know that [ __ ] is fun man a lot
of fun a lot of toys how many times have
you been to Coachella miss you've never
been to the festival just come and kick
it it's great come kick it out here is
you know I woke up we were I was just
doing this I did this I did this until I
fell asleep at the kitchen table yeah
I just fell asleep but didn't even put
my head down then fell asleep we were
jamming out cuz I was doing the drugs
use the theremin at one point he was so
high he just hit his head on the kitchen
table he was going like this so as you
know here the weed maps houses lots of
different vendors with different
marijuana products sharing them
yesterday and I just woke up in my
clothes with just a jar of wheat falls
out joint falls out a vaporizer falls
out of my pocket there's some gummies
yeah look crazy you eat you were going
in on those gummies man I'm different I
feel like I'm different as a human being
if that's how much that's how high I got
yesterday I would I'm a different man
than I was
yeah I feel like I was so high that if
somebody tried to convert me to
Christianity it would have worked that's
how high I was what if like there's a
man who's Jesus and his brain he's where
he's gonna come back tomorrow yeah
because you get because you can get
really drunk it's still you can hang in
your like you like we could power
through this but when you get high is
like time to go home
yeah it's time to go yeah left the party
at its peak speaker of Jesus Easter is
tomorrow yeah and people are you know
Kendricks album came out and now people
have the theory that
Rick will release a second album
tomorrow because he dropped his first
album yeah on Good Friday
and he's didn't Sunday his we're set is
here yeah it's on Easter
yeah when Jesus rose his thing would
Easter that I don't really [ __ ] with
that's just not even the same weekend
every year sometimes as citizen March
what the [ __ ] is that yeah is it March
how to win it how do they pick Easter do
they just throw darts of some [ __ ] Jesus
now it was this day for Jesus and let's
bring some eggs into the picture what is
the hell yeah I don't get the where did
that whole rabbit and eggs thing come
from
what the easily somebody some genius
that wanted to make money yeah pagans
pagans the pagans it's weird
rabbits and eggs and stuff it's just you
know it's funny you all can't see it but
it's just and they would I appreciate
the information but it's funny getting
schooled on the history of a tradition
but somebody with glitter on their face
[Laughter]
you're hardcore atheist
why are you ducking you right here
they're in and out do you have our next
guest here
no yeah next guest but yeah
festivals man it's a good time but you
sometimes people get left out there
oh hi and [ __ ] yeah I remember going to
Bonnaroo and just seeing somebody laid
out in the middle of the field do in
boxer briefs
yeah just boxer briefs your where's your
wallet happens often where's your wallet
where's the keys where's your stuff
where's your phone where's your friends
just laid out you see Molly mouths
everywhere everywhere everywhere Molly
mouths Molly mouth
I try to liquor the best
the other stuff I just panicked
mushrooms that was fun though you gotta
admit it was fun with the first kick it
was fun but then it just got to be too
much and then I started being fake deep
on mushrooms with my girls watch it
watch the rapper perform and then that's
heard over to heard tripping on
mushrooms hey babe
isn't it crazy how some songs are hits
and some songs aren't yeah that is crazy
too much psychedelics what do you are
mushrooms man oh really
you must have started peeking Wow oh
[ __ ] hates me also good it's a fart
right now you tip too [ __ ] you did too
[ __ ] let's actor actually did you head
sure sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know hey what is this show entertain
my back people oh man this is fun to do
so distract ourselves from the fact that
the world is burning funny Coachella
everything everything is festive right
oh man it's a good time man I was
thinking about that yesterday it's
because it was just you know a lot of
good rap music playing a lot of space to
move around yeah beautiful women
everybody's chilling and I was like this
is a good distraction from the world
yeah it was so freaky like there was a
guy literally at the bar the whole night
he had a like maybe like a pound of weed
yeah and he was just rolling it the
whole time
yeah like the whole night he was there
just roll it's the weed Maps house just
handing out joint I was like [ __ ] we
this is a huge compound is great set up
we maps they yeah I got mine just who
knew how much money there was and just
tell them people wish it is yeah do we
only think nah we just tell you where it
is
I mean it's not basically Google and
Google tell you where those anyway
there's where you get it I'll help you
get there I hope you get there ain't got
[ __ ] to do what happened when you get
there yeah but I'll let you know where
it is I don't know if y'all caught a
viable we're stalling you work at
another song
[Music]
was that no I don't want to join if you
uh if I smoke that joint this whole
thing will take crazy direction even
though it already took a direction a
crazy direction it's only who else you
excited to see I was excited to see
Travis Scott that sucks
I get to see you alright uh Laura
Radiohead definitely they will be last
night Oh miss them too
uh I think man there's so many goochy
goochy who else is on the rest I got a
we got to get those passes yeah
future yeah a lot see future already
late twice I'm cool yeah let's get it go
on you guys
please welcome trust me everything when
you see this or hear it it's gonna cut
together great you're gonna be like yeah
that event was net that smooth
post-production will take care of
anything all right
please welcome our next guest to the
stage from the vice land show dc's and
marrow
dc's and marrow yeah uh it's uh
everybody stone yeah I just want to blow
somebody up there's a bathroom right
outside there then I just utilized to
take a piss and there's doodoo on the
mat Oh
what do you [ __ ] [ __ ] on the floor and
then it clean it up I feel like this you
know damn I'll win yesterday yeah yeah
how'd it go home a slice scrub my boxers
on some juice - yeah a DAB dabs is white
crack really all a crack yeah
yeah once the people was like Marilyn
yeah it's uh it's incense man uh y'all
y'all second any performances today know
about a pool
you took you set on fire pole I was
before before who's a big performance
today at Coachella
like I know salon to perform in Gucci
future yeah
[Laughter]
could you if you knew your favorite rap
battle probably having an erection would
you still listen first of all you gotta
call you back to me I wanna have you
ever ask your doctor if your heart is
healthy enough for sex no and you never
will I feel like you know if your heart
is healthy enough versus like if you
pumping away and I halfway through that
your legs start tingling you slow down
you lean upon the black of mouth hold I
go that's all you module show it's just
too good like nah [ __ ] before whoppers
a day
I'm sorry my heart is a healthy enough
for sex I don't wanna live it over be
same for skin for skin here for skin
gang squad up chameleons and brought
down Cosby and noted for ski knowledge
it's like Corvette with a bow on it
that's like what your foreskin is it's
that cover you know saying we're sore
because I prize
[Laughter]
yo you think he's not Connie was saying
I feels awkward eye contact yeah well
when you get in the head looking at you
in the eyes I never know how to like
react look you got to look them in the
eye bro
it's weird man that's like that's like
but it works in afar is to like if a
lion is some [ __ ] you got a look at them
the same way you look at a girl's top of
you off like solid erotic but well
aggressive you know I'm saying like no
the problem is we grew up in New York so
if someone in New York makes eye contact
with you for over five seconds they're
trying to fight you every now that you
gotta fall back you'd be looking like
yeah yeah no I don't get more ideas east
side nickel suck is a weird song live
distinct beanie man check
[Laughter]
[Music]
squarespace.com trouble code Hannibal
get 10% off your first purchase
yeah it's just do it you need a better
website
it's slick they got money they're giving
me money to say it so I'm speaking from
my heart even though my website is a
Squarespace I'm just in too deep to do
the shift right now it's just but if I
was starting a new website I would use
Squarespace but right now it says the
way my hosting is set up I can't I can't
right now
squarespace.com promo code
hable get a great website life is kind
of tough sometimes and you can have to
process situations and do so how do you
do it in this day and age how can you
check out talk space.com slow scalable
talk space it's a tax based therapy talk
space is tax based therapy you sign up
at the website you sign you to a
therapist that can help you here needs
to Bruce and then you talk to him talk
about check notes yeah once you James
your feelings and jab and help you up
it's classic I reviews oh boy
sure grateful for its are the road so
check it over talk space back house most
honorable $30 off yeah $30 off about
that Hannibal talk space
[Music]
I'll start now
not yet but people wanna sue so I guess
I gotta do like some wild move you were
the police kill me or some [ __ ]
yeah I mean I gotta get that Emmy is
these I kissed a guy so I gotta get that
Emmy I could do bad movies like dunzo
that's the game plan there you go
believers all your movie and I got like
half cornrows yeah I'm married to Oprah
in it no what are y'all what are y'all
bumper right now what song it's on
repeat
you know I've rode in a helicopter
yesterday so surprisingly a lot of
Drake's last album you plan just to
relate he has bigger problems I realize
I also rich [ __ ] [ __ ] so now my girls
put the phone in the bowl now understand
like ladies I do having a girl out of
nga where she comes to my house like
that refers to kids right I can't do
that you live a bronze [ __ ] out of here
I don't [ __ ] MBA was that future of
course cuz I'm just coming back you know
I probably don't have kids I don't take
care of so I correlate okay okay respect
yo this is crazy cuz I'm four children
for what's the kid after like your
second child you people gotta stop to
congratulate you that was just
accidental I'm about here I was like
four four kids I got a great for an
office I'm saying
we are doing it make it moves doing a
lot with a little
I'm saying I got a big-ass dick oh yeah
Baga for kids I'm [ __ ] Lucy that was
that was that was the thing I'm a dad
yeah [ __ ] with Lucy yeah Lulu's is not
you know I'm saying like you're not
washed if you don't you know I'm saying
if you don't [ __ ] around but if you do
you're not unwashed I'm saying man go
back he's like yo
I was hoping he was making noise with
the [ __ ] to like yeah make it more crazy
[Music]
about playboy Carty right in there so I
listened to the album yesterday and I
found a song that I really liked and I
was listen to that [ __ ] on repeat is
called do that [ __ ] was supposed to be
exactly like I couldn't get a good
mortgage [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm our deficient
ya gotta pay for termites
just as iam I got a septic issue gotta
get that [ __ ] they say flushable on the
package but they're now really that's
just marketing position I bet you use
the baby wipes no but I should I don't
know when we go from baby wipes to
toilet paper why as we get older do we
treat our [ __ ] worse true we talk
about
yeah yeah okay cuz that yeah yeah you're
right
yeah yeah buffet you got three minutes
what do you grab you get just got a
Chinese buffet buffet you call two souls
general sales but if you know hood you
say general two souls are gonna look at
you like they don't know what you're
talking about
if you say general too so if you say
general Tsao if you like if I was a
learn the correct pronunciation in
Mandarin and say it they would be like
what the [ __ ] you doing two souls oh
they want you to miss okay this on
purpose that's how you get the free egg
roll yeah yeah oh [ __ ] that was well egg
rolls
yeah wontons the pan-fried joints fried
joints I recently discovered crab
rangoon I don't know uh faith so this
[ __ ] ain't crispy probably I mean I'll
[ __ ] with it I go on this I use always
got smoked before a buffet yeah like the
buffet you know go on this over drop his
little one Super's little drop high
sours flames pass our soup if you are
wild [ __ ] up han seung-soo bald you
down yeah I'm saying uh and then they
always got like the prawns in sushi that
looks like it's still alive yeah I'll
get someone else just to [ __ ] just leave
them on my plate you go but your Jersey
now so the place to you about your
Chinese food from they don't have
bulletproof glass anymore right no they
do I'm very cool I'm adjacent to Madison
you moved to Jersey was your neighbor
not yet oh you don't see me he's on the
other side okay
now I'm very close to Patterson I'm not
hip Addison okay cuz like that would be
I feel like that's a lateral move yeah
moving from the Bronx to Patterson
yeah I got a gay I got a two-car garage
Oh out here the brand is droves
yeah well he's got toys now bro I don't
even know yet but there's what the
neighborhood sent me a chart you fill me
in the mail dog yeah yes the I'll [ __ ]
with Easter I [ __ ] with you still
because I got kids and they get candy
and then that become
like there's a bunny and kids I mean
yeah brisket get your brisket sandwich
another special brisket on if you want
sauces B's my guys 1938 making a mouse
alright check them out on Vice land if
you turn it on the TV
that's right on Vice land they're
probably gonna be on I'm a French left
man early thank you fellas
alright this is a good time let's
welcome our next guest to the stage oh
we got another guest yeah okay
from wait wait don't tell me on NPR oh
yeah
please welcome my good friend Brian
Babylon so Brian Brian Babylon yeah on
the bill welcome
we first time we Coachella no no no this
is my this is my second and a half time
yeah first time was great saw ACDC saw
tame impala saw Drizzy saw the weekend
yeah that was a weekend I realized the
white girls loved the weekend wait who
did you who do you think they liked or I
don't know they was I don't know he he
activates them really the weekend like
what happened different schoolteachers
like I don't know a schoolteacher will
do Molly in this little weekend again
loose and to and then go back to
teaching go back to teaching wait
cuz kids is crazies kids would make you
stressed out is he able to maintain that
falsetto live I will say for a person of
his girth cuz he's not you know
weekends chunky is gonna do no yeah he
got like a lot of baby fat
oh under all his layers of clothes
alright and he was prancing around hold
falsetto notes and shape it stuff it's
falsetto in the desert I just imagine
it's tough I don't know anything about
stinking pock
yeah and we were amazed on how he was
playing the drums and singing he was
drugged that was tough drumming drumming
and singing at the same time and have
been like light drumming like just ya
know this is a real talent what's that
what's their work out that a lot of
people are doing with the ropes and they
just got the ropes yeah it's like doing
that and singing at the same time right
to thousands of people
pressure it's a lot of pressure that's
LeBron James level she's your type
things I didn't know how I was even
doing this I'm happy to see you guys I
miss you guys yesterday
[Laughter]
I had a wild night yeah what happened
Jesus I'll do cocaine stories okay was
it cool did you snap out know what [ __ ]
you know what I know why do you smoke
weed was pulled that but no cuz that
seems like a terrible weed hi no Coke
into the wheel and it's so depressing
ARRIRAW is the responsible cousin of
cocaine where you just do homework
cleanup and you're not sucking dick butt
in there like weed strains that could
keep you focused instead of taking
adderall after day at this point I smoke
too much weed for that oh yes I don't
know cocaine and forty-year-old
divorcees who like trying to get their
groove back is dangerous okay what are
your tender filters set up completely
available from 30 to 55 Plus yeah cuz
you sent me a profile of somebody that
was 57 and I'm like how do you even see
that bro I learned I just let him rip
man yeah yeah we saw I saw a certain a
screencap of Rolanda is on tinder yeah a
few people don't know who Rolanda is she
was the one back when it was real by her
y'all talking about Oprah back when
Oprah was just and every black woman of
a certain age is getting a talk-show
Rolanda was one of them it was Bertie's
he was Rolanda he was like a host [ __ ]
load up Rhonda was trying to get her
groove back sorry to interrupt you I was
I didn't want you to blow over lined up
like that
she blown up she's all tender yes yeah
talking about you know a good profile
had a quality from quality pitches
different hairdos
and that's what did you match with her
did not match with her like I was little
I was little like funky Rolanda no you
saw me damn I'm just kidding it's tough
out there man good stuff out there
Coachella tender Coachella Bumble well I
didn't did you see the there were like a
lot of ads for bumbles on the expressway
what is it
me and Marcus saw a lot of ads for the
bumbles okay
and it was like girls make first move
that's like best best that's what that's
the noise a lady makes on the inside
when they match with a real cool Jam
yeah Wow his profile doesn't have him
with a fish or shooting guns shooting
guns or on a car you know what my will
bumble women say the first line yeah and
what I've noticed is that women are
terrible at opening horrible horrible
terrible I've seen a few of just an
emoji sometimes they're good sometimes
someone like you know what there you go
I mean you're not a comedian but you got
some wit and you got your ovaries as an
overdrive right now and I appreciate it
some is like I could tell you copy and
paste at this yeah well here's a here's
a question when you're like Scott like
say you see a girl that you know and
you're scrolling through pictures what's
always like the deal-breaker that that
happen that happens often like the
deal-breaker if you have in 2017 if you
have fuzzy ass pictures get the [ __ ] out
of here
in 2017 if you have a picture with like
demon eyeballs get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah like it why don't you choose that
demon ass eyeball Paltrow and you get so
many filters that are for free that
could correct that situation for you
okay get out of here if you are with
your dog and your dog is kissing you in
the mouth get the [ __ ] out of frickin
2017 okay if you of course the basics if
you have a filthy ass
three track grass please shut up if you
have like why you got a fondue set only
oh nice damn [ __ ] what is that yeah
okay
but at the core if you
I have me now Jackson saw this this
chick had every picture was with her and
clearly her ex-husband at their wedding
yeah get out of here
no one's want to get cuckold unless you
ask me directly okay I get it and last
but not least I would say my number one
pet peeve and it's not a pet peeve is
white girls that go to the Peace Corps
and take pictures with women kids in
third-world country get the [ __ ] out
smiling with African kids all right yeah
I don't
I rather I rather you have a picture
with you at a ghetto-ass cookout on the
west side of Chicago
yeah yeah to some [ __ ] yeah that's more
real you just kickin it all of you if
she's on the grill yeah do it get in the
ribs and [ __ ] yeah that's better than
the African kid family care picture yeah
and this next one doesn't mean this next
one isn't me okay we'll close out on
this yeah if you if you take a picture
with your mom's and she's older and you
guys look gets a like and she's not that
hot I shouldn't see that cuz you saw you
show me like where this could go
oh [ __ ] I say up front that was mean and
I thought you about to say if the mom
looks better than the daughters like
don't put yourself next to your mom know
I've seen my whoa this is like a Marty
McFly situation oh this indicator is
that's the handsome Ramblers do's and
don'ts of profiles so she knows you're
doing it don't ya
you're individuals so cold
yeah no something with good tips they
were good tips that's good ten solid
bumbling tender tips from Brian Babylon
check them out you add Brian Babylon on
Twitter great fruit grapefruit I wanna
break you off a deuce in that boo-boo
what the [ __ ] did you know yeah I stick
to you just like glue ooh had no clue
Oh wanna play the boy gambler never got
it never understood it plus my mama
never bought it oh I was so full at a
young age they thought it was for the
family had me hide my face okay a peep
through the fingers already seen [ __ ]
working I was already yeah
check check check what's happening hey
guys we're here Coachella Hannibal
Burres co-host Tony trim a special guest
DRAM may be drawn damn drip drop drip
tray DRAM DRAM hey drink Keith stop for
pizza DRAM hey [ __ ] dream some [ __ ]
can't call me D ran deep racing hey
Duran Duran Duran Duran's acronyms wrong
burlesque music derivative from drama
just drop the egg drop a more does real
as music big baby yeah Rob yo shout out
the Hannibal because I swear to God at
the ESPYs party
he's just say what's up draw
and I'm looking at like you Hannibal
[ __ ] Birds he knew who the [ __ ] I was
sometimes I speak to people I say what's
up sometimes say what's up I'm usually
drunk if I'm drunk yeah I was out using
a whole last tuxedo at a party and it
was it was people mismatching hard they
was trying to mismatch no I was a whole
last truxedo yeah I don't a suit not a
tux oh I was dancers I was fresh yeah no
I like to just mix it up in our classes
all it looks good and edited when you
all of a sudden don't have glasses then
you have glasses so for a move yeah so
yeah and then how's the set last night
Coachella yesterday evening we don't
have Coachella passes so we can't we
couldn't go yeah man we didn't get I
[Music]
[Laughter]
mean I'm just saying drop you but see
some wild [ __ ] like that around festival
I've seen it yeah Hollywood Boulevard
what do you think too much or just
enough gotta bring in a close proximity
there No so how was the vibe on stage it
was electric that you did it feel
different from any other festivals it
was like a milestone moment feels more
it serves so many more purposes it's
just a show a tunnel I was like trying
to get over there so trying to be before
it like all in the moment its Coachella
and I didn't even think I was doing
Coachella this year
the fact I'm doing it to this stature is
lit yeah and I mean I was just trying to
just seize the moment man yeah did you
get anybody crowd surfing during you
said nope I jumped in all about to jump
in yeah I said you know what no it's not
worth it on a soft part of the crowd
yeah people with bad accent I sink in
then I'm lit yeah because I jumped and
gave it my all
yeah well I'm sure during broccoli you
could do that and I mean we'll catch you
because they're so live right assuming
when big baby laughs that goddamn rock
they lose among of course they do six to
six I'll deejay down at the club in
every single time if people everyone
singing along it goes I drop the volume
I'd like that song is just a banger
that's did you all know that that would
hit right away in the studio or did it
take getting it out to the people to see
the reaction the people the people yeah
well you just said this is a solid song
gonna be cool for sound culture yeah and
the coaches said now it's gonna be lit
for a world that's my go-to when I DJ
when the crowd seems like they're dying
I dropped that on them and I'll bring
him back to life that's lit was like
that prime song you mean like yeah yeah
yeah that's all get them back get him
back with Prai if I lose the crowd I get
him back with broccoli works every time
you all some of the dates on the Family
Matters tour with chains right you know
I did Boston with him like every every
time in London we was just you know we
was in the same area at the same sounds
like
bro you all [ __ ] like you brush my and
it just be let every time that's the bro
yeah yo they really keep you just got a
fool you've got an interlude you just
sing what you got your own track cuz it
was you know yeah yeah you make melody
you make melodies that like man you make
the catchiest melt like honey what's
your process cuz your cuz the way your
melodies hit it's like is gold right off
top always like it's so catchy like you
saying like the even the babies be
smiling to your music it's like you know
how you got like that thumbs-up and
thumbs-down meter right yeah yeah let it
be thumbs down before it's thumbs in
between because then there's nothing
it's not even memorable yeah yeah just
work on that and just be true to
yourself and go at it yeah you'll know
about the third or fourth time if this
[ __ ] in your calling yeah yeah yeah yeah
I was like I was talking more about like
the process like would you like do you
just hum hum around in your head and
then I like that talk to me I try to
talk back to it yeah and then we can
form our own type of language yeah yeah
yeah and make our although so you walk
to the beach you don't just have
melodies in your head like I gotta get
this yeah it's just rocking it away like
somebody like splash yeah I don't know
it's just everyday life ever since I
could think of thought it was always
infused with music I got you
it's in your blood I got you you you'll
just uh I've met you a couple times you
seem like you always in a good mood man
mm-hmm
your good vibes thanks man like bright
light
I come from Hampton Virginia you do yoga
nope you exercise a lot nope meditation
meditate I say my prayer before every
meal I say my grace yeah
good lord down upon me sanctify this
heart of mine and I'm so grateful for
this that I'm about to receive tax your
blessings upon it in Jesus name I pray
amen
you have a saint grace faced ass and
drama singing over our prayer face ass
it has to be the closest somebody
singing to the Lord and saying face as
those things happen in that we think
this is this history big baby it's not
we're here at the revolve house it's
loud as [ __ ] no you know it's loud and
me it's me is loud and medium I guess
it's loud cuz it's now it's intruding on
our vibe yeah
but the vibe ain't like outside yes
master
yeah no no I'm I don't know right feel
like a lot of loud music and no in
between jargon and make it feel like
it's lit yeah yeah it's a uh it's an
interesting vibe in it coach a lot of
beautiful women a lot of beautiful ways
where we're doing this reverse great
because they all dressed alike so you
just uh you just be like yo I saw you
last round a bit it won't even hurt
so shoot your shot again you might Swiss
how'd you celebrate the set last night
I got litters Jenga Jenga Jenga
yeah yeah knock it over knock it over
Jenga [ __ ] it just you want me to play
just knock it over
I lost y'all lost and then walk away
I think this dog needs a walk do you
have to buy extra plane ticket for your
dog dogs on album cover yeah
oh that's right okay and they're so cute
ID NIT surfing and it's so cute is it
Goldendoodle one years old his birthday
August 30th 2015
he's a golden doodle golden doodle so he
doesn't shed he don't [ __ ] damn so
you've clothes always lookin see cuz I
got a dog and his sheds as I can never
look crispy I always got a couple hours
late on me you'll roll over yeah he only
roll over for them treats though he he
only moved for winning a me he's still a
puppy go right he's a cute dog I love is
he gonna get bigger I think I think I
think you're gonna max out right here
he's oh he's a runt then cuz usually
these guys are nice so if you got your
minis
yeah that's your medium got the big-ass
wolf joints yeah yeah and like all of
them are cute and lovable yeah I said
lord I want the medium one you want the
medium so he like clocks in at 3040
pounds he clocks in at 20 20 now I
suppose we like 20 yeah it's cool for
the listeners oh he's got a dad a denim
jacket on and he looks cool as [ __ ] does
your dog does he have an Instagram
account yep his Instagram is in it so
cute how many followers you got
[Laughter]
you know you're you have a sample to dog
you know a lot of people ask that no
[Music]
yeah yeah just look I really love the
fact I was able to get like I never
could have a dog why dog you know will
you know my my momma's husband step hot
smoke oh gee well he's saying no dogs
and then they come to find out he had a
dog coming up that's not gonna talk
about it another time another time I got
my own I wasn't able to get my dog until
I was able to get and care for and take
care of my own so that's his first big
purchase it was the dog
yeah so you bring him on tour with you
he was on my tour yet we we had a tour
bus sort of like a big baby drum tour
yeah yeah so he's very well socialized
yeah it's good dog you could tell he's a
good dog but now it's who you excited to
see here Coachella
Kendrick Lamar engineers church on
Sunday it's Church honks OH
Tunde you ugly boy put some socks on I
don't even see your [ __ ] ass for
you are listening someone named Sunday
just walked past the [ __ ] out of that's
my [ __ ]
that's the first cast just just getting
roasted all of a sudden so you do here
so we going back to Kendrick did you
hear the rumor about or I they say that
he's supposed to drop a second album on
Sunday do you hear about that like fan
waiting for Sunday cause it's Church
Kendrick Lamar's performing at Coachella
it was the resurrection and they didn't
I'd all this [ __ ] saying that he's got a
second album ready to go for Sunday
Easter day on Sunday for his performance
at Coachella is gonna be church so you
didn't hear the theory is what I'm Tom I
was like a fan no I'm waiting for
[ __ ] kids right they step on
that stage Sunday church yeah
Sunday's back Sunday in this is my
manager tune the tune day since day one
go in 2014 bro he took a flight from
Atlanta up to Norfolk Virginia took me
and Gabe something it's not that far
[Laughter]
2014 yeah Brad this [ __ ] flew up and
was like bro
I'm [ __ ] with Charo with so that's
what Sunday you want happen real quick
you know either so you saw some of the
drop stuff online planes yeah you shot
him an email like yo I like all your
music I want to come meet you tomorrow
in Virginia and I bought a flight and I
was in Virginia
the next day Norfolk is a weird cities
when I might have been a five on the
dollar black he premium for the airport
okay yeah that's dope man he was like yo
your feet ashes [ __ ] we do that on the
wax because we already got to smooth it
out but his feet still ass you got there
where that lotion you need shea butter
you got shea butter Twitter on your side
puts a butter Twitter on your goddamn
ankles Oh drum just say for it you got
unlimited production budget for a show
what type of [ __ ] you're doing in that
show y'all bring it home the mothership
yeah I'm making it 1979 again bro with
the skulls that [ __ ] up I'm bringing out
George Clinton and I'm gonna be like
breath can you please with sound out
there big homey joy yeah
yo that's the big home but now I'm
bringing on the mothership if ever
yeah alright hey man thanks for sitting
and talking with us taking a little
break from the party I appreciate you
man much continued success yeah drop
everybody big basil jello slice ease
you
[Music]